welcome back to future chain design this
is pj today let's talk about how to make
this crown ring and how to arrange the
pattern correctly for this design are
you ready let's get started
[Applause]
all right let's starting from the
scratch uh every time when you're making
a ring you want to make an exact ring
size from my experience because yes
maybe they will shrink a little bit
during the printing but
you will also polish and that will size
up your ring size as well
so that's using the circle making a
diameter for 16 millimeter or whatever
size that you would like to make
we didn't want to use uh the lens
command and to find out this is 50.25
265 millimeter i'm going to make a copy
there and using the line tool
to create a line is exactly the same
length all right so we're gonna do the
design right there depends on the size
that the element that you're going to
design for so let's say i'm going to
divide this guy
into
maybe 12 section there
and this is the size of each section
that i would like to have so my design
area will be something about this size
for about whatever how tall you want so
that will be my design area it is just
for the reference now you have this one
you know each of them is going to
overlapping a little bit so you can make
this wider if you want to but i i just
wanted to make sure that you have a
reference there now coming into the top
view we are going to do our design i
also like to draw a straight line right
in the middle so i know where my design
is going to look like now you can go
ahead to use this uh you can draw or
trace your design over there but there's
a one thing i don't use much but i find
it useful in this
application
is when you have all the curve that you
can draw there's a ones called sketch
you can actually just using your mouse
to draw something like this
and um i should have a disable my point
because it keeps snapping into
the near so let me turn this one
off on the disable and we want to draw
it again let's draw something look like
this as a s-shape and it's coming out
like this
and then um it will
automatically make it look nicer a
little bit then you can turn on a
control point and keep adding like say
this is gonna come back
maybe we have too many points i want to
delete one here
and this one gonna go more close to the
center and you can do whatever
adjustment that you feel is necessary
okay now we have this one here let's
just simply pipe it and see how it goes
so we are going to pipe
eyeball whatever the diameter that
worked for you and i feel like this is
not as pretty right and it has a little
bit kink there so what we can do is
actually use the smooth command
to make it a little bit smoother
um we're going to use
for
going to i mean x y z that we it
actually doesn't apply to the z just x
and y
and we can make it something a little
bit smoother like this and let's click
ok
once you click ok let's pipe it one more
time and see if we have a last kink over
there all right so it's much better but
the head is still a little bit narrow so
i may wanted to have the head coming out
like
this or maybe i don't need the very last
point because it's gonna end up a ball
there all right if i like this one i'm
gonna
detail into
my pipe uh beginning of the pipe it will
be about this size at the end of the
pipe i actually like it a little bit
bigger so i will have something like
that as you can see the belly over here
is sticking out which is fine because
that's exactly what i'm looking forward
to
when i have everybody is overlapping a
little bit in fact i need to have this
one coming in a little bit so i'm going
to have a pipe uh make sure you record a
history i want to have a pipe about here
and the pipe about this size right there
and hit enter right now you can turn on
the control point and you can bring this
one
a bit to the right side
so they will be touching there alright
so now you have this one um i also need
to have a ball there so let's go ahead
to create a sphere and i'm going to
snapping into this endpoint and to get
something like this all right i'm gonna
snapping something like this all right
double check if they are in the same
high if that is correct and if that is
what you're looking for just go ahead to
boolean
maybe bringing a little bit
inside like this and we're just gonna go
ahead to select all of this and we're
gonna boil in union together all right
it would say well break the history
that's okay we are not gonna changing
anything now if you take a look on the
render view you're going to see there's
a really sharp line there it doesn't
look good so i'm gonna use the commands
for further edges and let's do something
really small like a
0.15
and see how it goes
this edge is there and this edge is
there
all right it looked pretty smooth there
and so we're gonna keep it there so
let's go back to the ghost view now we
are going to have this one and i'm going
to mirror to the other side
like this so you have the upside down
heart shape there um and then if that is
a
it look nice and we can flow to
to the ring you may also have a question
say let's say i'm going to have a stone
there so i already have a stone sitting
in the prawn set and it's going to put
it there should i flow the seed
or should i working the seat on the ring
my answer is working to see on the ring
you don't need to float it it will
deform it your stone a little bit which
is not gonna be pretty so we are going
to moving the stone that i have put it
there for us to use if you want to know
how to make this stone setting i
actually have a whole playlist for the
stone setting and if you want to do
know more about different type of stone
setting and fancy card
how to holding the stone certain prong
size you can check out
my online course for song setting okay
come back here
we don't want this just like that we
actually want to have the bottom to be
thicker right so what i like to do
is coming over to the top view i'm going
to draw a box something like this and go
a little bit deeper there
and then we're going to use the bowling
union
this guy out of this guy all right so
now we have this button is completely
flat that's using the gumball
and holding the control shift and click
on this surface and we want to extrude
it longer all right how long do you need
it to it's really depends on how thick
that you want your ring to be i think
this is a bit too long so i'm going to
bring back for something look like
one and a half
millimeter
okay so something like this should work
now we need to have this one
flow to here you could have just moving
this one sitting there and doing the
polar array that will work too but i
like the button to be routed and follow
the ring shank so we are going to use
the command flow
and we want to float this guy
oh before we move it i actually need to
show you some little trick there
now if you click on this one and you
want to coming into the curve tool you
want to know the adjust curve
seam
it's going to show the seam is right
there all right so i'm going to move the
seam to the bottom it doesn't matter
where you face it and that's the bottom
i'm also mean like the one that i have
this should be right in the middle of
this curve so my design was sitting on
the top all right so we want to do is a
line vertical
and we want to align this line to this
line and hit enter
and then so it was sitting there let me
just did it
this curve here so it's not bothering
you so this one is sitting right in the
middle of this curve all right we're
going to use the um flow command and
we're going to pick up this object and
hit right here and also hit the one on
the ring
all right
see the ring is much lower than what i
want is because
the object is actually lower
uh for my reference point so that i
forgot to change it we're gonna pick up
the object at the right view and that's
a line to the bottom and just type it
zero so it's sitting above the
construction plane let's flow it one
more time
we're gonna float this guy
snapping to the base curve
and snapping to the target curve all
right so now it is sitting there
remember how many sections that we have
one two three four five six so we got 12
section there that also mean
we're going to
maybe this need to be a little bit
bigger
um and then it's going to set it right
there
and going to have it move it up
like this all right just need to make
sure it's not sticking inside of a ring
shank like this we want to go something
like this all right if everything looks
all right to you
i actually will select everything
and we are going to come in here
with a polar array type it zero and we
do want to have 12 of them and for 360
degree and we will get something like
this
now to to all this joint right there
it's a little bit too thin so that's
also creating a base
and before we do that that's moving this
circle out a little bit i'm going to use
a county corner on the rectangle
and snapping right there
making a square
roughly about this size
and then
with the really round corner and we are
going to use the sweep command so let's
go ahead to sweep one
rail cross section and we'll get
something like this now we just need to
put this one back to here and make sure
it's touching so you'll have a good
rendering there
all right so this is the rendering and
that will be our crown ring if you like
the way i do the model please join the
membership i have over 100 additional
video in the membership program that you
can watch 24 7 to learn more about
rhino3d model thank you for watching and
i will see you next
[Music]
you